you've been playing a law enforcement
agent now for seven years
yeah and all day long on these shows you
have to get there early in the morning
put on the makeup yeah at the prop gun
and then all day long you're playing a
law enforcement if you ever feel like a
cop after all this time do you revealed
yourself like hey cuz I remembered once
I only bring it up because once I was
dressed as a cop for some bit we were
doing and literally if they put on the
suit now for five minutes where I
wandered away from the set and started
to like tell people to move it along
yeah it gives you that power yeah did
you ever have no because that would be
delusional
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you'd be Tom Cruise no I think that um I
you know we've done 195 episodes or
something insane which is like 15
thousand hours of playing a cop and
what's crazy about this is you go to
work and they give you a real gun and to
give you an m9 or some like massive
machine gun and some explosion happens
or or or or something crazy happens and
then they all action and you run towards
it right instinctually when something
goes wrong you find yourself just being
the guy that runs towards the action and
I actually have a terrible story where
that happened in real life and I'm
driving on on the 10 freeway
I'm in a far left lane and this is this
black windowless van blows by me on the
on the on the corner in the side lane
and hits the Porsche in front of me
knocking off their mirror I can hear the
woman screaming from my car I
immediately jump on the phone i call
9-1-1 to say 9-1-1 what's your emergency
and I said this is black windowless van
traveling eastbound on the 10 freeway
license plate tango Charlie 371 and the
woman goes okay where are you right now
I said well I'm on ten we are now
crossing the 405 under pursuit and she
goes what and I go what and she goes
what and she goes dude sir I'm sorry sir
did you just say pursuit and I said no
no no no I should go sir are you
following the vehicle and I was like no
no no I'm not following - sir do not
follow the vehicle we've called officers
do not follow view and then in front of
me it's like a Michael Bay movie like I
see the windowless van hit the center
divider it creams to the right of
Porsche launches into the air a Volvo
spins to the right I go to the far right
lane and fire up to the end and now this
is this van that's gone across all this
traffic that's stopped is like a five
car pileup and it's teetering on the
side and as soon as I
up the guy jumps out of the van and he
rips his shirt off and he runs across
now four lanes of stop traffic jumps the
center divider there's now traffic going
at full speed going westbound on the 10
and he starts screaming there's been an
accident
there's been an accident and I realize
in this moment like there's somebody in
the back of this van because I've done
195 episodes
there's a kid in that person in the back
of the van so I jump out of my car and I
run to the front of the van and I go
hello is anyone in there and there's no
response right which means one thing
that they've been been handcuffed and
bounding okay and so I go around to the
back of that van and the windows are all
been blacked out and so I'm staying low
so if this is the back of the van I'm
staying low so when the shotgun shoots
out the back windows it doesn't hit me
and I'm going like this I'm about to
breach the van because I've done like
you know 55 tactical breaches on the TV
show that's fake and I'm about to go
into the vehicle I'm leaning through
like this and I look down and I'm
holding my finger
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all the people have come out of their
cars and they're watching the spectacle
in front of them which is this crazy man
without his shirt on meth trying to stop
cars and then that idiot kid on NC SLA
who's about to breach a van with his
finger but that didn't stop me no no no
the moment I go like yeah no no no I
have to hide that she's act there and
she's probably bleeding and so I swing
and open and of course there's nothing
there but no one there for sure somebody
has a picture of me as an idiot on the
10 freeway but that just you know when
you do this many hours you just get
excited you get excited you you think
that you're this guy and also I think
you would be a very good cop I think
that what we're learning you know if you
yeah like if you look at LAPD they don't
they don't I look homeless
[Laughter]
you